durant plusieurs années avant 1988 m
haies jones avait travaillé comme prêtre
curé et vicaire de différentes paroisses
puis aussi comme aumônier dans un
hôpital de montréal également dans deux
maisons pour jeunes filles en difficulté
c'est à 59 ans alors que la plupart
d'entre nous envisageons un retraite la
vie professionnelle que la seconde
carrière d'aimer jones commence quand il
crée avec sa roulotte des sans abri
l'organisme le bon dieu dans la rue le
bon dieu dans la rue est plus tard
devenu dans la rue tout court pour
enlever la référence religieuse en
gardant la même mission humanitaire
d'aider les jeunes sans les juger a dit
que s'il n'aurait pas été logique et
d'inviter poor's 500 linge sans souliers
sympa que je vis parce que là j'ai
encore la déplaçant les jeunes ont ce
problème beaucoup de nos jeunes ont ce
problème là aujourd'hui d'autres ont
pris la relève mais l'oeuvre de l'homme
est bien vivante
l'organisme dans la rue multiplient en
fait les initiatives nouvelles depuis
quelques années il faut créer des
conditions d'accueil suffisante pour que
les gens puissent se tourner vers autre
chose
nous on est en itinérance genève et donc
on le fait encore plus parce que pour
les jeunes c'est vraiment des moments
charnières
l'idée c'est d'éviter qu'en fait les
jeunes deviennent itinérant chronique
adultes cc larbaud et directrice
générale de dans la rue il ya plus que
3000 temps abri à montréal alors déjà
assez difficile de les compter tous
parce qu'on a qu'on appelle de
l'itinérance cacher il ya beaucoup de
jeunes qui ne sont pas dans les rues
mais qui ont besoin de services
d'accompagnement qui en endroit pour
reloger mais c'est toujours plus ou
moins stable et s'est d'autre part et
3000 une journée donnée donc dans une
année il ya des gens qui vont être dans
la rue pendant quelques jours pendant un
mois puis cela être sont occupés aussi
parce que ils ont besoin de serbie dans
la rue organisée à l'automne dernier une
nuit dans la rue un événement interactif
au cours duquel une cinquantaine de
personnalités publiques des gens
d'affaires par exemple ont passé une
nuit à l'extérieur pour vivre une
expérience immersive et se sensibiliser
à la réalité des jeunes sans abri ils
ont choisi une nuit
en octobre alors que le véritable test
c'est une nuit en janvier par les moins
30 moins 25 degrés celsius comme la nuit
dernière par exemple je suis allé voir
le centre de jour et c'est
impressionnant de voir combien de jeunes
et inera qu'on ne voit à peu près pas
dans notre vie quotidienne
robert dumas président de la financière
sun life
ce qui est impressionnant c'est l'état
de précarité dans laquelle vivent quand
je dis jeunes cela peut être aussi jeune
que douze heures qui sont à montréal
sans domicile souvent malade mentalement
avec des problèmes de drogue ou de
consommation d'alcool toutes sortes de
preuves un comportement à risque et qui
n'ont aucune aucun espoir est qu'une
personne à qui parler
c'était la sévérité de la précarité de
ces gens là qui viennent nous chercher
mais en parallèle ce qui est magnifique
c'est qu'il ya des gens qui attendent
quelques pas puis qui leur donne une
lueur d'espoir le père emmett johns a
changé le regard que pose la société sur
les sans abri au québec et il a inspiré
plusieurs personnalités artistiques et
politiques à mener leurs propres actions
pour revoir nos approches nos
perceptions surtout par rapport aux
sans-abri - quand on rejette je peux
être d avoir des jours à me remettre en
question pas me faire du centre cochon
commun je serais moi me faire rejeter
des centaines de fois par jour parce que
c'est seul bonhomme que la bonne femme
qui vit dans la rue qu'on ignore qu on
ne regarde pas on lui envoie tout un
message après une série documentaire
appelé face à la rue l'animateur jean
marie lapointe poursuivre l automne
dernier sa réflexion sur l'itinérance
dans le livre aide face à la rue publié
chez libre expression
ça prend pour grand chose pour bascule
etc et il ya plusieurs personnes qui me
posaient des questions par rapport à la
part aussi parce que c'est une paire de
finir je type son recul il ya plusieurs
millions d'années on est toutes des prix
matin on vient clan vie dans la jungle
en club sont le malheur d'être exclu par
note qu'un c'est la mort qui nous attend
a reçu et c'est qu'on croise dans la rue
elle qui vivent seules la cedh est exclu
en lice ont dans la jungle de la ville
exclu et nous on n'aime pas savoir ce à
ce que c'est notre peur à l'intérieur de
notre arme viennent disent que si nous
est-ce qu'on n'a pas de virer comme les
autres moi j'ai l'impression qu'à départ
comme ceux qui nous rendent malades
venant d'un confortable mais je pense
que c'est l'antidote l'antidote
une fois que la peur est assez si la
compassion c'est la seule façon c'est de
tendre la main mais avant même de tendre
la main
prenons le temps de les regarder dans
les yeux avec lui de chaque humain est
important et c'est ce qu'on doit retenir
je pense chaque humain une valeur chaque
à venir des capacités j'aimais le déclic
comme chevalier pour les sans abri
vraiment quelqu'un de la qui donnait une
voix à nos jeunes marginalisés
c'est un une page qui se tourne pour
dans la rue mais il laisse un héritage
très très solide
un reportage de radio canada
international